what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
God so I will be honest secret Empire
just keeps getting better and better I
mean damn this story is so good I've
been telling people ever since like
Captain America was revealed to be a
Hydra agent that this will go down as
one of the greatest runs in the history
of his character it's so different it's
so dynamic I mean I get that there are
those who are just who just don't like
change and that's fine but I think this
is just this is one of the greatest runs
and his character feathers ever been
because the way this ends is insane now
remember for those of you guys who are
joining us for the first time we kind of
have two stories going on simultaneously
right like we have what's going on out
in the real world which is Hydra Captain
America basically trying to eliminate
the last vestiges of the Avengers which
is basically whatever superheroes manage
to evade capture by Hydra and are
basically hiding out in Nevada alongside
Tony Stark trying to find the remnants
of the Cosmic Cube
so they can use it to basically adjust
reality and fix things back to the way
they need to be but then we also have
what's called the vanishing point right
now we don't know anything about the
vanishing point in the next like three
videos we'll know a lot about the
vanishing point and we will know just
how cool it is because do it oh my god I
really want to talk about stuff that's
going to happen I really want to talk
about future things but it's it's really
really cool it's a really cool set of
event but the indication here at least
in the early stages as we you know as we
see it right now the vanishing point
seems to be where heroes go when they
die that really seems to be the case
because for the most part all the
characters that are here are basically
dead the only exception to that was Sam
Wilson Bucky Barnes was killed in the
events leading up to secret Empire Red
Skull was killed in the events leading
up the secret empire and even this you
know classic as we call on classic Steve
Rogers himself is you know
metaphorically dead and he's been
replaced with Hydra Captain America and
so that's the question that people are
asking and that's the question that I
cannot answer is is Hydra Captain
America even Captain America is all this
going on inside of his own head or is it
a wholly different location is it
actually just another dimension is it
something taking place inside the shards
of the Cosmic Cube these are answers
that we don't have Rockets questions we
don't have the answer to in this video
we'll have answers to that question
later on but the idea here is that this
again focus
on the nature of the fact that classic
steve rogers has basically just been
taken prisoner by red skull inside of
the inside of the vanishing point so
again at this point we switch over to
new york city now remember one of the
things that we had talked about is the
idea that New York City had basically
been whisked away to a place called the
dark zone the dark realm or whatever you
want to call it but it's basically a
place of total darkness the only source
of light that exists comes in the form
of dagger and she's basically a
character that can kind of create like
these hard light constructs to a degree
she's basically serving as this light
atop the Empire State Building as a way
to basically light the city as best she
can the problem with this is that the
use of her powers takes a physical toll
on her body her entire body goes into
creating light the more she does it the
more it burns her out she's pushing
herself to the point of exhaustion and
so because of this what we end up
finding out is that Stephen strange is
basically trying to find a way to access
a spell or something that will break
them out of this whole dimension now one
of the crazy things that happens here is
he initially addresses a guy called the
librarian and I've never heard of this
guy before I don't really know anything
about him I poked around online and I
cannot find like a thing on this guy the
librarian he's virtually non-existent
the only way that I can think this
character really makes any kind of sense
is if we were to come to the conclusion
that writer Nick Spencer is basically
drawing on Jonathan Hickman's whole idea
of the sinners market now the sinners
market was a concept that was invented I
believed during Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers and is basically this this
other dimension is other dimensional
place where people who can delve in the
mystic arts can go to in order to
basically barter life energy for power
now there's other things to go into it
in terms just being able to buy like
black-market spells and things like that
that's really what it is it's just like
a giant black market when it comes to
mysticism and magic and different things
like that but that's the only thing that
I could make with this guy but again
with Stephen strange what he's basically
trying to do is just find some spells
that will let him break out of this
whole Dark Dimension area now of course
at this point we switch over to one of
the coolest engagements which actually
takes place between kingpin and
daredevil and the reason why is because
with New York City having been whisked
away to this Dark Dimension what is
basically done is this allowed whatever
criminals remain in the city to
basically run rampant but so it's really
just daredevil trying to crack
the moral in trying to get everything
back together and basically call it a
day but the other half of this is that
Wilson Fisk never does anything out of
altruism which is to say because it's
the right thing to do
Wilson Fisk always want something in
return and that's really the the
situation is being brought here when
daredevil jumps in and basically defeats
a handful of Wilson Fisk's men who are
basically taking all these different
medicines and so on and so forth you
know the question is asked why is Wilson
Fisk helping these hospitals and these
these churches and so on and so forth
why is he contributing to that and the
answer to Wilson Fisk is because when
this is all done they will remember
Wilson Fisk has always tried to make New
York City his own Kingdom and in a lot
of ways he has where we had daredevil
during the whole shadow land story and
then we basically had camp in picking up
the pieces and using what was left of
shadow land to form his own empire which
is kind of cool basically corralling the
hand for those of you guys who are
following the whole defenders Netflix
thing essentially what seems to be going
on with the defenders is this shadow
land story
- daredevil being possessed by like the
Beast so the you know entity that's a
hand basically warship that's really the
only difference everything else seems to
be pretty much the exact same I could be
wrong but that basically seems to be the
case that defenders is going to be
shadow land and if it is I am hyped
because that story is so good but the
idea here is that if Wilson Fisk cannot
take over the city of New York through
force then why not take city of the city
of New York by winning the hearts and
minds of people who were there the idea
was that mobsters would basically win
over neighborhoods they would win people
by giving them things so that people
would be less likely to rat out the
actions of the mob when the cops come
walking around asking questions what's
this guy been doing have you seen
anything suspicious people will say no
everything's been fine as far as I'm
concerned and the cops can't make their
case
Wilson Fisk is walking this exact same
line when the hearts and minds of the
community and the community becomes
yours on a larger scale when the hearts
and minds of New York and New York
becomes yours and so again it says
really cool concept but at this point we
switch back over to red skull and his
whole interrogation with classic Captain
America now again the implication that's
given is that classic Captain America
does not know who the Red Skull is and
that again raises even more questions if
business classic Captain America and
this is red skull how does classic
Captain America not know
ohoo Red Skull is they've been fighting
forever and ever and ever and ever and
that's one of the things that Red Skull
brings up everything that's transpired
up to this point is because of this war
the superhero community has been
fighting for everything I'm fighting for
eons and eons amongst each other amongst
other villains so on and so forth it's
just been going on and on and on and on
and so when the question is asked is it
possible to escape this place the answer
given by Red Skull is that the only
place to escape is through pain and
through death now of course this
transitions over to the champions now
remember when it came to the champions
they were basically coming out of the
Avengers they looked at the Avengers
team and they said the problem with the
Avengers is they go in they fight
villains and then they give no thought
to what happens afterwards the role of
the champions which is to say basically
these younger teenagers more or less
young avengers effectively was to come
through and say okay not only are we
going to defeat the villains we're going
to help people rebuild because that's
what superheroes should be doing and the
way in which this transpired was just by
virtue of them you know doing what they
could when they could but when secret
empire ultimately popped off they
basically ended up you know siding
against Captain America joining Iron Man
which eventually led to them joining
with the ranks of Black Widow who
harbored this idea of just killing
Captain America because of how
villainous he was but what ends up
taking place here is that some of the
members of the champions do not see eye
to eye with what it is that Black Widow
is doing specifically because of the
fact their Black Widow is making some
friends out of some pretty unsavory
enemies case in point
Viper like we talked about in the last
video Viper was a pretty minor villain I
mean she just kind of appear off and on
different things like that but she was a
criminal first and she was a human being
second and the idea was that when secret
Empire basically began to happen when
Captain America instituted his Hydra
regime Viper as part of Hydra began
running her own narcotics ring basically
buying and selling drugs and the result
is that if Captain America were to find
out he would basically have her executed
the problem with this is that with Black
Widow basically going to Viper and
essentially saying I know everything
that you're doing I know what's going on
with Maria hill doing the exact same
thing and then basically passionates
information on it resulted in the idea
that the champions are now aligned
themselves with effectively a villain
but that's the nature of war right like
the enemy of my enemy is my friend it's
not clean it's not clear-cut and that's
the difference between the champions
characters like Black Widow initially
Black Widow kind of looks at this and
says what was our fault that we did this
is our fault you know that we basically
just got into conflict after conflict
it's our fault that we were fighting
amongst each other so much we failed to
see that the most significant enemy was
the one that we didn't expect
ie Captain America as a Hydra agent
Black Widow looking at this and saying
we brought this on ourselves but Black
Widow also recognizes that the buyers of
war are not absolute there's no good
guys and bad guys there's the guys who
think they're right and then the other
guys who think they're right and they're
both fighting each other but when you're
the champions when you're young when you
see the world through rose-colored
glasses you don't see how it is you see
the world how you would like it to be
and regardless of how you would like the
world to be the world is a certain way
and because of that the champions
haven't quite stepped in to the notion
of realizing commit us all it's not just
black and white there's not good guys
and bad guys that there's all different
shades of good guys and there's all
different shades of that guys black
widow needs to kill Captain America and
she'll ally or herself with whoever she
needs to in order to make that happen
but for the champions right wrong or
otherwise they stick to their guns and
say no vipers a bad guy we do not ally
ourselves with bad guys but again when
the questions also raised as to why they
broke this old man out of a hospital the
answer is not given by black widow now
that old guy is actually going to be
pretty significant he's going to be a
pretty huge character when it comes to
the forces of Black Widow trying to
topple Captain America I really can't
emphasize how important he is and I'm
kind of curious what you guys think who
do you guys think that old man is this
is a guy that's going to help turn the
tide it's really going to help move
things in a new direction but of course
the idea here is that we switch back
over to Hydra Captain America what we
end up getting is this great monologue
from him which he's always got amazing
amazing monologues in the story
alongside what it is that the Avengers
are doing and what we end up finding out
is that the forces of Tony Stark
basically have this massive bunker
they've been operating out of and the
bunker was designed to withstand the
strength of Thor it was designed to
withstand the abilities of vision to
phase through solid matter it's designed
to withstand virtually everything the
Avengers could account for it at the
time that all this is going on Captain
America basically says it was only ever
a matter of time before something like
this happened when it came to the earth
superheroes they were all obsessed with
their own individual goals and that
really kind of hits home at the nature
of Marvel's
superheroes Marvel superheroes in a lot
of ways are grounded they're very
personal they really focus on the nature
of people the avengers aren't
necessarily a tried-and-true superhero
team so much as they are a group of
heroes who came together for like a
particular cause but they all have their
own motivations they all have their own
desires the goals they're trying to
achieve Tony Stark is a futurist he's
always looking to the future you've got
like Widow who's carrying all her
baggage from the Red Room you've got
Mockingbird who's trying to prove she's
legit you've got Quicksilver who's just
trying to get his sister back nobody's
really looking at this and saying we are
a cohesive team people are looking at
this and saying we're just the last
vestiges of what superheroes used to be
and we're just holding out trying to
find the Cosmic Cube and then maybe
we'll win and that's really that's all
they have and Hydra Captain America
knows that and it's the coolest thing
because what he did is he basically
turncoat somebody he made them into a
spy and all it would take is someone to
realize that's the case and to say
someone here is a spy and then that just
becomes self-destruction because they're
so selfish because they're motivated by
their own desires their own goals at the
end of the day the enemy isn't
necessarily Hydra Captain America the
enemy is their inability to function as
a team to put their problems aside and
focus on a common common enemy for any
real measure of time now of course or
the poking and prodding begins to go
around in terms of the families of the
individual characters who it is us doing
this who it is doing that what we also
end up finding out is that this speech
that's being given by Captain America is
being given to Bruce Banner remember
Bruce banners back we don't really know
how and the idea here is that Captain
America hits home at the notion of the
reason why it is other superheroes
always opposed Bruce Banner because
remember it wasn't necessarily the fact
that banner was the Hulk that led a lot
of superheroes to turn against him even
when he was just banner they didn't
necessarily take him seriously the
scientific community didn't necessarily
take him seriously for the most part
when he was a superhero reaching out to
banner for advice or help on something
he was the last guy they would go to in
some cases they would go to villains
before they went to Bruce Banner he was
the total lack of trust the total
disconnect between them and how they
view Banner and the cool thing about
this is Captain America says the reason
why is because you represent an
unquantifiable concept you represent
something that cannot be controlled that
cannot be contained you represent
something that people just cannot
fight you are the quintessential example
of absolute pure and total chaos because
that's what the whole kids and that's
what Captain America says the Hulk is
just this uncontrollable thing this
force of nature but the funny thing
about this is that banners response is
but you're a Hydra agent you are not a
good guy and that's the cool thing here
is because it's not like everybody just
kind of looks at this and says you know
is hydration you know and what can you
say and that happens sometimes they
don't ban it it's like the one guy who's
been gone this entire time he's just
kind of resurrected or ever the case
maybe he comes to and suddenly Captain
America's a Hydra agent and hydras taken
over the country and so we're banner
initially says okay I can't do this I'm
not going to side with you Captain
America's response is yeah but I wasn't
talking to you Bruce Banner which is
when the Hulk emerges and it is man it
is a sight to behold because like we
said the Hulk is just pure conflict just
pure chaos and that's the crazy thing
because where Scott Lang finally comes
clean and says I'm the spy for Hydra
they have my daughter Cassie
they basically shanghaied me in and said
if you want your daughter to live you're
going to spy on Tony Stark's team when
all this information basically becomes
to the Hulk emerges and that's the
caveat to all this because Tony started
to count it for everything at that point
in time Bruce Banner the Hulk was dead
there was no reason to believe that he
was going to come back there was no
reason to believe that he would be alive
Tony Stark did not account for this just
incalculable unlimited strength of a
force of nature just coming down on the
avengers headquarters like the wrath of
God nobody expected that to happen but
that's exactly what happens the Hulk
just smashes in and suddenly this entire
bunker is all for naught because all it
takes now are the forces of Hydra
Captain America to come waltzing in
while this is happening The Incredible
Hulk is recalling the events of what it
is it took place during Civil War two
when Hawkeye shot Bruce Banner killed
him with an arrow when Bruce Banner felt
betrayed when Bruce Banner felt cheated
that's why the Hulk is just raging so
much because all this pent-up emotion is
this feeling of betrayal this feeling of
deception this belief that the
superheroes had turned against him for
no real reason whatsoever at the behest
of Carol Danvers all this is coming home
to roost and
now the Incredible Hulk is letting it
all out but remember the Incredible Hulk
se was being resurrected was only ever
temporary again we don't know why we
don't know if magic was used we don't
know if he was like resurrected by
Captain America using for the hand all
we know is that the Incredible Hulk was
brought back for a temporary amount of
time the result of this is that in the
midst of the ensuing chaos in the midst
of the conflict Odin's son shows up but
instead of just quashing any of the
civilians that are trying to get out
instead of just killing every superhero
he comes across he basically allows them
to pass now remember in the last video
we talked about Odin's sons loyalties
Odin son is not loyal to Hydra Captain
America he does not believe that Hydra
Captain America is doing the right thing
he is not okay with what's happening the
loyalties of Odin's son is to Mjolnir is
to the hammer and by his logic if
Captain America can lift the hammer
Captain America is worthy if Captain
America is worthy then own son should
follow him because if he wasn't worthy
if he wasn't righteous he wouldn't be
able to lift the hammer so again it's a
pretty cool scenario it's a pretty cool
set of events now again you know kind of
go into the comments of the the
different videos that we've talked about
with your Garza Thor's hammer I mean
there's some you know who are just kind
of like no no only good guys can lift a
hammer but like we talked about before
the cause of the hammer is not
predicated on good guys it's predicated
on work that's just the nature of the
hammer that's just how it works and so
again
it's one of these cool things because
this ultimately leads to a fight between
Captain America and Iron Man himself now
of course would be incredible hope just
kind of fading out you know really just
more or less just dying I just going
back to being dead not really sure the
cases with him what is it happening is
Tony Stark almost stops Captain America
dead in his tracks and the reason why is
because what he does is he apologizes
this is one of the great things about
secret Empire it draws on everything
that's happened in Marvel Comics in like
the last 10 years maybe even 15 years
Tony Stark even starts talking about the
events of the first Civil War he thought
that he was right he believes that he
was doing the right thing but when the
conflict was done when it was all said
and over and I went to smoke cleared it
wasn't worth it I mean he draws on the
story to confession those you guys have
never read it
Civil War the confession is basically
event via the story it's really like a
one-shot that takes place directly after
the events of the death of Captain
America and it's only Tony Stark and his
only Captain America no one else's in
that story unless they're in like a
flashback or something like that but
what Tony Stark did in that if you
basically confessed and said it wasn't
worth it if I known this Civil War was
going to result in your debt I never
would have instigated this conflict in
the first place because Captain America
stands for hope he stands for the belief
in a better tomorrow and that's kind of
the funny thing about this is because if
you look at Captain America right now he
still does
I mean sure Hydra is a fascist
organization right like they're
basically taking over the country and
ruling it in an iron fist but one of the
things that we saw when this story first
kicked off is that there's jobs that are
increasing the stock market's better
people aren't struggling for money for
the most part Society in and of itself
is inherently better so long as you're
the right kind of citizen and that's the
difference here that's the caveat how
much are people willing to sacrifice in
order to make things better is it one of
those things or people are willing to
sit down and say yeah man hydras running
the show and it kind of sucks if you're
that guy but for me it's cool and now
what happens if that guy who says it's
cool Hydra comes knocking on his door if
he's still going to say that if you're
still going to say no everything's fine
man yeah take me away as cool I don't
mind take me off to jail I don't have a
problem with that because society is
better of course not
the guy's gonna say well no no no all
right I mean you know I'm get that guy
don't get me you know I'm good I'm fine
everybody's okay with the status quo and
so the status quo shifts and then the
powers-that-be start coming after them
what we end up finding out is that the
other member is really a lie so the one
that basically brought Steve Rogers into
Hydra when he was a child and she
basically ends up where at least her
forces begin picking up some rear signal
emanating from the Avengers headquarters
only for us to find out that what Tony
Stark has effectively done is activated
a tactical nuke and detonates it
basically nukes the entirety of Avengers
headquarters and anybody who was there
and so this is massive because anybody
who didn't get out of the impact of this
nuclear bomb is dead they're gone we
don't know who those people are yet but
if they were there they're up in smoke
and so what is up happening here is
Black Widow is listening to the events
unfold and basically comes to the
realization with as far as she's
concerned as far as she knows all the
Avengers are dead they're all gone they
just poof like that in a nuclear
explosion if they weren't like four
or somebody like that they couldn't
survive it and so in the last little
tail bit of his story what she does is
wake up the champions with the intention
of travelling to hide the headquarters
and killing Captain America but with
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the raw pork you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
Oh